let's talk about Rick Perry Rick Perry
was governor of Texas he's a Republican
he's Donald Trump's Secretary of Energy
and he is an evangelical Christian
through and through and if you had any
doubt about that he believes and he told
Fox News that Donald Trump was chosen or
ordained by God to become president and
to do great things now if God chose
Donald Trump god either has a very
unusual sense of humor or is actually an
extraordinarily malicious actor let's
take a look at the video of Rick Perry
saying it in his own words God's used
imperfect people all through history
King David wasn't perfect Saul wasn't
perfect Solomon wasn't perfect and I
actually gave the president a little
one-pager on those Old Testament Kings
about a month ago and I shared with him
I said mr. president I know there are
people that say you know you said you
were the chosen one and and I said you
were I said if you're a believing
Christian you understand God's plan for
the people who rule and and and and
judge over us on this planet in our in
our government and less people on the
Left attack Rick Perry he pointed out to
me
he believes Barack Obama was sent by God
as well he said it for that moment in
that time he said he thinks for this
moment and this time
Donald Trump was sent by God to do great
things so we're gonna play the whole
clip later but I think it's interesting
now it's interesting how ed Henry slips
in that Perry also believes Obama was
selected by God but it's important
because they're trying to pretend to be
fair and balanced here
Trump was chosen by God to do great
things says Rick Perry which is very
different than why God would presumably
choose Barack Obama according to Rick
Perry's evangelical right-wing point of
view now this the the analysis says this
is of course completely bonkers but it
is not that rare among many of the
people that are around Donald Trump or
supporting Donald Trump Trump is of
course not at all religious he started
pretending to be religious when he ran
for president his infamous 2corinthians
quote claiming that the Bible is his
favorite book
than his own book art of the deal but as
we know we have seen this exact idea
that Trump is not only religious but was
chosen by God floated by a lot of the
people around Donald Trump one example
of someone we already talked about
earlier on today's program Trump's
second former press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who said that God quote
wanted Donald Trump to become president
and that's why he's their Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo said that it's
possible God raised Donald Trump from
the beginning to be president in order
to protect Israel from Iran white
evangelicals in general agree with this
idea in 2017 there was a survey done by
the Public Religion Research Institute
and more than half of white evangelicals
57% said that God played a quote major
role in Trump being elected president in
2016 so there's actually a lot of stuff
to disaggregate here number one we know
that 62% of Trumpets will never turn on
Trump no matter what he does that's from
a poll about three weeks ago even
hypothetically there is nothing that
Donald Trump could do that would get
them to reconsider their support for
Donald Trump
I would guess that there's an overlap if
you imagine a Venn diagram of the people
who think Trump was chosen by God and
the people who would never reconsider
supporting Donald Trump that 62% of his
supporters if you believe Donald Trump
was chosen by God of course you wouldn't
turn on him no matter what he does
because whatever crazy thing Trump does
must be part of God's plan again it's
obviously a closed logical loop that is
in defeasible there's no way to disprove
it but if that is what you believe that
is logical reasoning based on the
completely bogus premises that are
required in order to get to that point
that's number one number two as far as
Trump goes in terms of his relationship
to Christianity Trump aside from it
being an obvious lie that he's a
religious person Trump goes against
essentially every stated
Christian belief now stated is an
important word which I'll come back to
momentarily Trump is an adulterer
he has been pro-choice his entire life
he's a liar he's a cheat he's been found
legally liable for defrauding both
students and veterans on and on and on
but what matters isn't whether you've
actually lived the life that adheres to
the stated evangelical Christian values
or not what matters is are you saying
the right stuff today and do you claim
to be against abortion today and Donald
Trump is the proof of this that above
all proof confirms this is the reality
for so many particularly white
evangelicals in the United States Donald
Trump embodies the opposite of what
evangelicals claim to value but he does
say he's against abortion Hillary
Clinton was pro-choice and this is
basically all you need to know in a
great sense there's something insidious
happening on the american right which we
haven't talked about much the american
right is generally considered to
fetishize the constitution almost as if
it were a sacred text but there's an
extremist evangelical Christian
contingent I guess we would call it
we're sure the Constitution's fine but
in reality they would prefer to do away
with separation of church and state and
to make the United States functionally a
Christian theocracy they don't deify the
Constitution they would rather it be
replaced with Christian theology a sort
of Christian version of Sharia law and
that is a very very scary thing and
there's actually been there's a few
interesting documentaries recently some
fictionalized and some other TV series
or or films I would say some
fictionalized and some not that point
this out and it is really really scary
stuff and Rick Perry's comment is just
the the tip of the iceberg so to speak